. We have a voicemail number, which is two
one nine two David P. I've gotten a lot of
questions about.
I know that this is it sounds unbelievable.
But the right now has a new date on which
they believe Trump is going to come to power
the conspiracy, right?
They believe it's March 4th.
Here's a viewer asking about it.
Yes, David, this is Alan calling from Texas,
and I've been reading a bunch of stuff online
about March the 4th being the day that Heuvelen
believes Donald Trump will come back into
power.
Right.
And has to do with a law that changed the
date when the inauguration of the president.
Yes, it moved from March to January.
That's exactly right.
There are some kuhnen types that are floating
a pretty convoluted conspiracy theory which
says Trump is going to be inaugurated on March
4th and he's going to be president of the
United States.
And what what this comes from is that before
1937, presidents would be inaugurated on March
4th, and then it was changed by the 20th Amendment
to January 20th.
So there are kuhnen types and sovereign citizen
types and some of the fringe groups that talk
about a deep state and all these different
things.
They are claiming that on March 4th, under
a restored republic, that will go back to
the sort of presidential timeline of presidents
inaugurated on March 4th prior to 1937.
Trump's going to be sworn in that I hope I'm
doing justice to something completely crazy
that doesn't even deserve justice being done.
But that's my understanding of the theory.
And it's not going to happen.
We were told that by December 14th, Trump
was going to be the apparent winner, the president
elect.
We were told then by January six that was
going to be we were told that something would
happen by January 20th.
Joe Biden's president, Joe Biden, will be
president on March 4th and 5th and 6th and
7th and on.
But, yes, there's always something.
And to be honest, I actually don't know if
these conspiracy theories are being created
because there's money in it for somebody like
is there a financial incentive here where
people are somehow monetizing these theories
or is it really just people desperate not
to accept reality?
I don't know the answer to that.
We will talk about the Dallas Mavericks national
anthem controversy on today's bonus show.
We will talk about Joe Biden policy with China.
We will talk about those stories and much
more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.